minimums
[Music]
Auto property
200.
1
speed
let's see
50 40. 30 20.
10. five
that was one year ago Tomorrow People on
December 17 2021 when we landed in the
Free State of Florida and I have to say
that this has been uh well without
question the best year of my life and
that we have two new babies over here
and Life's Good In The Free State but it
has also been the fastest year of my
life I cannot believe how much has
changed in just a year it's it's
absolutely wild today is December 16
2022 I'm Dave Rubin as always uh we are
live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
Blaze TV uh share subscribe all that
stuff if you have not and actually this
video which appears to you to be live
right now is pre-taped because the
Reuben report party was last night and I
wanted my guys to have a good time you
never know what's going to happen at a
Reuben report party and I wanted to make
sure everybody could actually sleep a
little bit this morning so we're taping
this uh in your world yesterday but
let's just pretend it's live we're going
to do a real a little Reuben report
Community Q a for you this is the first
time ever that we've done two in one
week but it's just been crazy around
here and it's a good mix of questions I
think you'll dig it uh and uh before we
do that I want to talk a little bit
about I saw this bit this bit I guess
he's I guess it's a bit this schnick
from Stephen Colbert from comedian
Stephen Colbert going after Ron DeSantis
and it's like man I've been predicting
this for a good five months I'd say at
this point they are going to do the
Trump to DeSantis regardless of whatever
happens with Trump and DeSantis and
working it out or fighting it out or
whatever it might be they are going to
turn Ron DeSantis the mainstream media
they are going to try to turn him into
Hitler plus Hitler with an accountant
basically with the Calculator meaning
that he will just be the more functional
version of trump because he's the real
threat because he is doing everything
right and because he is younger and
competent and everything else so Colbert
went after him and just like an
absolutely crazy way we'll show you a
clip on that in just a second then get
to the Q a but before we do all that let
me talk to you guys about Mike box did
you know that 60 of us pork production
comes from one company owned by the
Chinese and their Hogs are given
something called ractopamine which is
banned in 160 countries including China
yet you find it in your grocery aisle
every day there's a better way guys I'd
like to tell you about moink that is Moo
plus oink moink delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and sustainable wild
caught Alaskan salmon straight to your
door boink Farmers Farm like our
grandparents did and as a result moink
meat tastes like it should because the
Family Farm Does It Better the point
difference is a difference you can taste
and you can feel good knowing you're
helping family farm stay financially
independent as well you choose the meat
delivered in every box like rib eyes to
chicken breasts pork chops salmon
fillets and much more plus you can
cancel anytime my personal favorite is
their filet mignon Shark Tank host Kevin
O'Leary called thanks bacon the best
bacon he's ever tasted and ringdale ring
doorbell founder Jamie simenov jumped at
the chance to invest in moink plus they
guarantee you'll say oink oink I'm so
glad I got moaked keep American farming
going by signing up at boinkbox.com
Reuben right now and listeners of this
show get free filet mignon in every
order for a year that's one of the best
filet mignon mignon you've ever tasted
but for a limited time
m-o-i-n-kbox.com rubenmoitbox.com Reuben
and now back to me so I don't like this
Stephen Colbert fellow very much he
replaced David Letterman who was
phenomenal David Letterman one of the
greatest late night hosts of all time to
me
and I'm of a certain age a 46 year old
Carson was the best Carson and he was
mostly before my time obviously I think
he retired in 1992 I was 16 but I was
just kind of getting into comedy I
remember staying up late night uh to
watch the show a little bit and as a
matter of fact staying up that last
night uh when he was signing off for the
last time he had Bette Midler as his
guest on that last show she sang him
wind beneath my wings uh Flash Forward
30 years she was calling me racist on
Twitter so life's weird what can I tell
you uh but Colbert has taken over for
Letterman and he's just he's just an
absolute partisan hacking you may
remember my conversation with Bill Maher
uh from a club random podcast couple of
months back where we were talking about
Colbert and I said you know he just
gives the machine whatever it wants
right if the machine wants you to be for
vax's he'll dance with a little vaccine
hat on he just gives whatever is
politically correct he calls everyone
racist all of that stuff and now he's
gone after DeSantis of course he's
always going after Trump but now he's
moving it on to DeSantis because I think
he sees what the future is uh here is a
I suppose we call this a comedy routine
by Stephen Colbert new Wall Street
Journal poll says that in a hypothetical
GOP Primary matchup DeSantis beats the
former president 52 percent to 38
percent
yay
also maybe boo it's hard to know who to
root for here it's like a poll between
gonorrhea and a slightly more racist
gonorrhea
this is
apologies to gonorrhea
this is all because well with the
insurrections and the Hitler dinners
only the most conservative voters are
still backing the ex-president while
DeSantis is trouncing him with voters
who consider themselves only somewhat
conservative basically the folks who
don't support gay marriage but think
Andy Cohen does a great job handling
those Housewives
[Applause]
I tried to laugh I tried I couldn't do
it I mean he's just awful he's syphilis
he is the syphilis of Comedy Stephen
Colbert you're the syphilis of Comedy
he's just absolutely awful and you can
see what the move is you can absolutely
see what the move is DeSantis will be
Trump but worse he's functional Trump
was just an idiot so if anything he's
kind of coming off as pro-trump there
right because it's like oh well this
other guy's coming and yeah and and also
like this idea that DeSantis has a
problem with gay people
it's so effing stupid and it's so deeply
dishonest and and also why why would
why would people run and uh support Ron
DeSantis why why would they I don't know
we got a couple points here well he did
keep Florida open with no mandates that
was pretty good uh Implement numerous
tax holidays to make sure that people
would be struggling a little bit less
during this economic downturn uh crime
in Florida has completely cratered
virtually everywhere that is a little
bit something to do with him backing law
enforcement he rebuilt the Sanibel
Causeway and did incredible stuff down
in Southwest Florida after Hurricane Ian
he expanded school choice for Florida's
families he provided 70 million to
bolster programs aimed at equipping dads
with parenting resources to help Foster
Youth and he gave parents the right to
know what kind of education their kids
are receiving that is just a small
amount on top of this massive uh covid
move that he's making where they are
going to actually have a grand jury to
look into what fauci and the CDC did and
everything else I know all of that
freedom is scary and he's not coming for
the gays or anyone else actually the
governor sent us two onesies for the
babies when we announced that we were
having kids you people are just
absolutely ridiculous the syphilis of
Comedy Stephen Colbert all right let's
get to a
reubenreport.locos.com community q a
Lawrence says I'm originally from Jersey
but living in North Carolina I have no
desire to live in Jersey again but when
I visit family I will take time to drive
by places I used to go often remarking
how great it used to be but no longer is
when you go back to LA do you drive by
your previous house and haunts and maybe
feel a bit nostalgic for how it once was
no I've been back twice uh in the year
since we moved from LA and first off
when you go there for everything here in
Florida and I'm in South Florida
obviously Miami air it's so Lush and
Alive literally there was an iguana not
an iguana there was a gecko in my uh
shower this morning just take taken
esteem in my shower I posted a picture
of it on Twitter there's just like a
life here and then and then there's
another type of life which is just happy
functional people going about their
business and things are just kind of
buzzing here and it's all good it is so
deeply depressing in Los Angeles the
people do not look happy the amount of
masks the misery everyone just kind of
walking with their head down uh and and
it and it doesn't feel Lively either
right I mean it really is a desert there
and and just nothing like looks Lush and
alive and any of that but when when uh
Phoenix and I went back a couple of
weeks ago for the the Bill Maher podcast
and we did some stuff with prageru
prageru is about a I don't know maybe
three quarters of a mile from where my
old house was I had no I loved that
house it was the most beautiful I could
have lived in that house the rest of my
life it was just in the wrong state but
I just had no desire to go back I felt
no attachment to anything I didn't miss
anything there there wasn't I didn't go
out to restaurants for the last two
years so there was no restaurant I
missed there was no store that I missed
or there was really no person I want to
see I mean I do like Prager obviously I
like Dennis and the Prager you people I
like Adam Carolla who's the other guy
that I like and I like Larry Elder I'm
trying to move them all here I literally
send them all listings on on Zillow and
Trulia all the time but no I don't feel
any Nostalgia for it I don't miss it at
all and it's like in a weird way when I
see these stories about La wants to you
know bring back mask mandates I'm kind
of like I'm kind of for it I don't mean
that in like I want to punish people I
mean it like the only way you will ever
change is if you get rid of these people
and you'll only get rid of these people
if it gets that bad so
is what it is uh Quinn says Dave what is
your least favorite thing about having
kids damn man we're not even five months
in over here my least favorite thing
look I mean the the sleeping thing
obviously is is some level
um you know I'd say one thing like as
sort of clear and clean and honest as I
can possibly be which is what I always
try to do on the show but it's a little
different when you're asking me about
the kids
um you know we had a really great life
before kids we have a great life now but
I do sometimes Miss like a little bit of
like the flexibility of my previous life
like I haven't been able to just like
Lounge in the pool on a Sunday lately
because like on a Sunday it's two of us
and the two kids and like somebody's
pooping and crying and screaming and
every now and again that's one of the
kids so
yeah I got you that time I got you that
time uh so I do miss a little bit of
what our life was like I know it's so
much more Fuller now and and the picture
is brighter and and higher contrast and
and more Everlasting now and all that
stuff but like there is some piece of
that like you know these last couple
years I've had a very Charmed Life I've
kind of done what I've wanted to do when
I've wanted to do it and I've built good
things and I work with great people and
we have good friends and you know so we
haven't seen people as much it's like
we're having less dinner parties that
sort of thing so I so it's not even
about the least favorite thing because
the stuff that involves them it's good
even when I'm getting spit up on it's
all right it's all right uh let's see
Nick says can you ex can you please
explain how so many people seem to agree
that the presidential candidate Gavin
Newsom is one of the most objectively
good-looking men in America even before
his hair turned gray his hair gel game
never even compared to yours thank you
thank you very much for the record this
is two types of spray there's a dry
texturizing spray and a super fine
hairspray it's a lot I'm inhaling a lot
of that David thinks it's either going
to kill me or it's preserving my insides
I'm not sure which one uh I I don't find
him attractive he looks like just like
an evil smug douchebag like if you
Googled evil smug douchebag can you
Google evil smug douchebag right now
like I'm pretty sure Gavin Newsom will
pop I got all you googling it that's
good I'm pretty sure it's going to be
Gavin Newsom like I know he just you
know he reads as uh as American Psycho
like he's just a bad dude I don't like
him but but I know I know what's her
name Sunny Hosten on The View finds him
very handsome so good luck with that Amy
Says should Sam bankman freed be worried
about meeting Jeffrey Epstein soon I'd
be more worried about meeting the last
people that Jeffrey Epstein saw that
would be a bigger issue
um yes I think it is very likely that he
is going to accidentally uh camera is
not going to work and he's going to slip
on a puddle or somehow something like
this guy knows too much something about
this story and I'm not a conspiracy
theorist but everything's a conspiracy
these days it's like something about
this story reeks we've shown you that
compilation video a couple times of like
the media just absolutely fellating this
guy over and over how he got in with
every celebrity how they were given
every politician on both sides though
mostly Democrats second largest donor
all of this cash something about this
reads like it's so connected to just the
general state of craziness and in an age
when texts and tweets and direct
messages and all that can be exposed
especially when you got a guy like Elon
involved it's like
a lot of people probably do not want him
to to be talking so we shall see Patty
says Dave when the study of fauci begins
can I be there for the lobotomy I need
first-hand proof that there is actually
a brain in there well Patty I you know
look there is a brain in there uh it's
about the moral choices that this guy is
making it's it's what's between I would
say his brain and his heart the
disconnect from here to here that's the
problem that the guy has
um you know it's funny I said on the
show a couple days ago that I don't know
that he's like inherently evil like did
he devote his life to all of this to do
evil things and sure he did do that
study where he locked dogs down put
their heads in a bag and let maggots eat
their faces off
I don't love that and I'm not sure what
science he was trying to get to on that
one
um but like was he like profoundly evil
when he started doing research about
AIDS in the 80s and then everything with
infectious disease and and then you
could say well he got drunk on his power
and he got into this gain of function
research where we started you know in
essence gaming these viruses to do more
and do different things and study them
and
try to keep him in a lab but you never
know what happens when that door swings
open and all of that stuff so I I don't
know that he's purely evil but I would
say this actually I would say at this
point his level of dishonesty relating
to what his previous actions were when
we have videos on all of those things
that I would say is pretty much evil
like the way he's going out in this
Blaze of Glory as if he had nothing to
do with any of this stuff and where he
literally sits there and basically tells
you that China's zero coveted policy is
kind of okay uh you know you wouldn't
want to do it forever but you know you
do it for a little while it's like
there's something evil about all of that
but yeah the lobotomy of fauci people
would I'd pay I'd pay uh Sweetwater says
are you a fan of desserts or do you
usually skip it and go for a drink or
tequila
you know I don't love the sweets I don't
love the sweets but I do love ice cream
so I guess that ice cream obviously is a
type of dessert and it's a often I love
uh you give me a nice mint chocolate
chip nice mint chocolate cookie I like
the mint flavors
um like peanut butter ice cream
something like that uh oat meal uh what
is it oat milk ice cream it's been
working for me lately uh there's a good
place not too far from here uh but you
know Tequila at the end of the night
will always be fine but for the Reuben
report holiday party we got some sick
ass Donuts you guys know we're gonna be
eating some crazy Donuts tonight which
has these people watch it it's yesterday
it's a whole time warp around here Eliza
says what is worse the view or CNN
oh that's tough I mean the view is just
like an endless onslaught of everything
decent and good in this world like that
these women sit there and they all agree
and they bring on the fake conservative
to agree with them and like and that
they're so wrong about everything and
the one that kills me the one that kills
me
is Joy because I was sort of friendly
with joy when I lived in New York City
and we lived a couple blocks away she
did my radio show a couple times I would
see her and her husband Steve on the
street and we would chat and say hi to
Emma our dog at the time and she wasn't
a bad person but politics makes everyone
crazy and it has a way of making
leftists particularly crazy because if
you only believe in like what's
happening right now and then what's
happening right now happens to be nutty
you will go nutty with it so listen to
her someone who I kind of liked and
respected maybe we had some differences
doesn't even matter to just watch her go
completely off the defense deep end
Trump derangement syndrome covet all the
stuff that one's been tough so the fact
that that show is just like that a
certain set of people just religiously
watch that and think they're watching
something saying seems dangerous as for
CNN I mean
CNN's awful too but uh but CNN has
really become the brunt of a giant joke
now I mean if anything I think we could
thank CNN for being so bad because I
think that that has has red pilled an
awful lot of people right so many people
now see how how part is it how patently
partisan CNN is that I think it's
actually woke up a lot of people and and
people are tuning out and tuning into
shows like this and I guess that's
probably not good uh Mike says hey Dave
I know you've always been a tequila type
of guy but now that you've officially
registered as a republican have you
thought about when you're going to
transition to brown liquor
look I get it conservatives
you know you meet a guy that's a
conservative he wants you to know that
he's a guy and how does he prove he's a
guy he drinks brown liquor does it taste
horrible yes does he say he likes it yes
does it get him drunk yes
conservatives love whiskey a bourbon I
have a ton of whiskey and bourbon in the
house right now oh and speaking of yeah
that would do it Connor loves this
bourbon it's called monkey shoulder
wherever he goes he's got a jar of
monkey shoulder with him he loves monkey
shoulder I don't like whiskey or bourbon
I just don't like it I like the smooth
delicious Taste of a beautiful Reposado
or animejo that's what's for me but I
respect the conservative who says I
drink
whiskey or bourbon I smoke a cigar and I
have hair in places that nobody should
have hair
Spike says hi Dave when do you announce
the Cali jar winner good question Spike
we are going to announce it next Friday
so next Friday will be our last show of
the year uh obviously giving everybody
uh some time off for Christmas and I got
a ton of family coming here and
everybody else is going home do their
holiday thing so we will announce the
Cali jar winner it will be somebody in
the locals Community uh and a whole
bunch of you have been submitting all
sorts of interesting somewhat often
funny requests about why you're
deserving of the money and I'm going to
throw in some extra money uh we're gonna
post about it again next week so you can
so we don't we make sure that we don't
miss anybody uh because the post have
been just flying in on uh on who thinks
that they deserve the cash to get out of
California and to move to the free state
of Florida if you want to get in on that
join us at reubenreport.locals.com uh
ski says do you think the first thing
the new Congress should do is tackle the
corruption
inside the FBI how will we ever get any
real investigations uh prosecutions of
all the corrupt politicians and the woke
CEOs colluding with the government do
you think it's even possible to clean up
the FBI at this point thanks for being a
sane voice in an insane World
um I actually do think it's possible
right I think Trump had all of the right
ideas related to the swamp and the and
the permanent state that just exists no
matter what of unelected bureaucrats
that just are kind of in all of the
halls of power in DC it was not
something that we all talked about
before if you remember when when Trump
regionally said deep State and everyone
said he's a crazy conspiracy theorist
but now we all accept that these
bureaucratic giant institutions CDC NIH
whatever is going on behind the scenes
in the intelligence services that these
things last over this this uh
Administration that Administration Etc
so I think it is possible to to this
assemble some of it the question is and
I think this is going to be a question
that pops up more and more over the next
year or so is okay Trump shined a light
on it he didn't do anything about it
when he was president but it was first
time in and I think he was a little over
his head as anybody would have been it
was really hard to staff and everything
else is he the guy to come back in and
really continue that work or is there
someone perhaps with the track record
that is better and obviously you know
who I'm talking about that would make
sense like he's got the right team
around him like the question that I
think Trump really has to answer still
is who's around him now who's around him
now you know a couple days ago Trump had
this announcement on Truth social that
he had a huge major announcement coming
the next day and people were like well
what could it be is he going to announce
his new foreign policy or that he's
doing this or that or you know something
and it was like he's selling nfts on his
website for 99 a pop like
is that what we need right now and he's
doing that at the exact same time that
DeSantis is doing this covid panel and
it's like I think you got the point I
think you got the point so I think
there's other I think there are some
people that can do some things related
to that I don't know if it can be Trump
Lloyd says where did you find Brock
great content
Brock is your name Lloyd in the
community did you submit this question
to yourself where do we find Brock well
you may remember a couple months ago we
we announced on the show and on social
media that we were hiring we got
hundreds if not thousands of resumes
plowed through them we have a little
system of how everything works where
Phoenix goes through some stuff Daphne
kind of filters them for me they take
some meetings then I take the you know
the final Zoom calls uh and Brock had an
awesome resume and I chatted with them
on the uh on the zoom he didn't fall out
of his chair which was half of it and uh
and and you're moving to Florida can I
say that I just announced it I don't
know yeah all right he's moving to
Florida he's here right now visiting
just checking out some stuff but he's
moving with his can I say fiance uh and
uh yeah so far so far so good and I'm
gonna call you Lloyd from now on because
clearly you're Lloyd uh me says the
amount of hate directed at DeSantis on
Twitter is unbelievable I watched his
round table on the kovid shots and
started reading comments before I
couldn't take it anymore do you see that
hate represented at all on the ground in
Florida or do you think it's mostly
trolls and bots on Twitter doing this I
don't see it anywhere I don't see it
anywhere here even the people
that so I'll tell you something I play
basketball with a bunch of guys I knew
one guy I was invited to this Weekly
game and I'm playing ball with these
guys and they're all good guys and it's
about basketball like we're not sitting
there having round tables about politics
anyway I started chatting with one guy
and it became fairly obvious that he was
a lefty he didn't he didn't know who I
was and I started asking a little bit
more and it seems like they're all kind
of lefties
um like just I think they're like a
little more old school Democrats or
they're like Florida Democrats I guess
that's the point so they're not like
completely bananas insane uh but so Eve
but my point is that even the the
Democrats here and and there are some
bad ones I would say like a Charlie
Chris type but even the the Democrats
here are a little more moderate than
what you would get of a let's say a
democrat in San Francisco or more
broadly Cali and parts of New York and
and you know Connecticut and all that
kind of stuff
um but Florida Florida is freaking
flourishing right now and I don't think
there's any hatred on the ground I
really don't I think people are really
happy about what's going on here the
proof's in the pudding the guy won by by
20 points and as for you know Bots and
trolls and YouTube comments and
everything else you know you've really
got to remember like for example our our
comments on YouTube are quite good
they're quite on point I'm very proud of
that that means that our base audience
is usually talking about the issues that
when I scan the comments every day and
it's just like people are paying
attention to the show they're asking
interesting questions I see people going
back and forth and everything else but
what you have to remember when you see a
video that has a ton of hate let's say a
video has a hundred thousand views right
hundred thousand views now if a hundred
thousand view video has 5 000 comments
that's five percent right which is a lot
because most people most of you watching
this right now you're watching it you're
either enjoying it or not enjoying it
hopefully you're enjoying it and then
you move on with your life but then
there's a certain set of people that
comment so it's a it's a self-selected
group of people and then the people that
comment for whatever reason as a general
rule and it's actually not happening
that much in our community they tend to
be angrier and the more crazy that you
write things the more likes that you'll
get the more responses that you'll get
and then you'll start fighting with
people then the average person looks at
comments and they go into the comment
section they're like man I guess people
really did hate this video or I guess
people really do hate Dave or whatever
it might be and it's like well actually
that's a self-selected group of five
percent of the people 95 percent of the
people probably watched it enjoyed it
and moved on with their lives so the
focus on the Bots and the trolls and the
anonymous comments I know why we all do
it and we think it's indicative of
something bigger but I actually think
that the the more important number to
look at is the amount of people that
watch and don't comment that just watch
and go oh I kind of agreed with that
kind of didn't agree with the other part
but hopefully I'll come back
Carlton
says can you give us a group picture of
you and the team of Reuben report
tonight
will you guys be willing to be in a
photograph
everyone's yeah everyone's everyone's
willing to be in a photograph at least
the people in this room
so yes there will be a Reuben Report
Team picture taken this evening posted
at Ruben report.locals.com
Patsy says my brother is a gay man who
has run radically to the left because he
thinks conservatives hate him he very
much buys into the idea that
lgbtq plus being a unified Community
although I'm not sure he's heard any
arguments suggesting otherwise I love
your advice on how to have the best
relationship oh I'd love your advice on
how to have the best relationship with
him since this has really thrown a
wrench in our siblinghood ah
it sucks and I'm sorry you're going
through it and I've heard this from a
million people and and it's also like
the obvious
reason why these these group identities
these collectivist identities are so
dangerous the simple truth is a gay man
has no more in common with the Trans
person than a straight person does it's
just the truth a gay man doesn't think
he's in the wrong body you that you're
talking about attraction versus identity
they've just combined all of these
things and they've done it in such a
dangerous way as I've talked about many
times and I've mentioned with a few
guests you know if you took a little
seven-year-old boy who was effeminate
and liked playing with Barbie instead of
GI Joe
these days the entire machine around
them would be encouraging them to
transition when most likely they will
just turn out to be a hopefully
functional gay person and live a live a
fully actualized life like anybody else
that would be the hope maybe they turn
out to be straight you know they're a
straight guys who are effeminate and
there are gay guys who are straight
acting Etc so as to what you can do with
that I mean maybe try said ended in one
of my videos
listening to some of this stuff like who
would want to be I I don't look at the
people that work for me that happen to
be straight and my base thought is
they're straight they must represent
straight people but there's this weird
thing that happens with gays or it's a
weird thing that happens with all
minorities in general but imagine
thinking that your political ideology
had to be deeply tied to what your
sexuality was how depressing that would
be and in a weird way it's like when
when the Democrats
you know Chris Rock does a bit about how
the cops need a certain amount of crime
and the Democrats need a certain amount
of hate the Democrats need the idea out
there that somehow conservatives or most
Americans hate gays and hate trans
people and hate hate this and hate that
because if they don't have that if they
don't have that idea out there by the
way it's just an idea it's not a reality
if they don't have that idea well then
why then a gay person might be like hmm
let's see I'm equal I have equal rights
I have a job I like to have a family and
own a car and a house and pay a mortgage
I'm gonna have to make some decisions
politically on my own I'd maybe like to
vote for lower taxes boy the Republicans
generally are for lower taxes my foreign
policy I'm not really that into Wars and
endless spending on things that does
seem like more of a republican ideal
these days so they need to keep you
focused on your identity they need black
people to think that for conservatives
are all racist and they need you to
think that you need to be on the
government Dole otherwise you would
realize you don't need them and that
ladies and gentlemen is what it's really
all about Tony says what is something in
the new year that you're looking forward
to
um you know well look this has been a
great as I said it's been an absolutely
great life-changing year
um we've got some big announcements I
think we're going to at least tease two
announcements uh next Friday but we got
some big things coming in the year just
in terms of the show and everything else
and and more than anything else what I
want for 2023 I mean we brought two new
lives into this world and into this home
I just want to make sure everybody's
happy and healthy and we keep doing that
I think we're gonna do a little more uh
travel I'm going to try to take the show
on the road a bit more I think we might
do some International stuff uh probably
in the spring of 2023 uh and just keep
building something good that that feels
valuable that when I wake up in the
morning I'm ready to go to work and and
hopefully that my team feels the same
way and that uh that we're making a
little bit of a dent you know like I
think more than anything else it's like
if I can imagine a little a little dent
in in this Machinery that has been so
calcified against us if I can be a
little bit of a part to wake up some
more people and have people take more
responsibility for their lives and and
maybe smile and laugh every now and
again when it comes to politics that
would be uh pretty pretty sweet if you
have not subscribed please do so at
rumble.com reubenreport if you want to
play along during these q and A's and
submit questions and possibly get the
cash to leave Cali and go to Florida
join us at
reubenreport.locals.com and by the way I
I say this every now and again but you
know you can join the locals Community
without paying you can't interact with
me but you still will get push
notifications I'll always be able to
contact you if I was to be kicked off
Twitter or Facebook or YouTube or
anywhere else so please do join us one
way or another uh and we've got a couple
interviews coming out this weekend
actually we did interviews with Senator
James Lankford and Senator Marsha
Blackburn uh that uh just in the last
day or two that will come out this
weekend
and I Leave You
with the elderly man pretending to be
president have a nice weekend I said at
the top of this forum about closing
deals and we've delivered
so just give me a few let's give you a
few highlights from the deal room to the
benefits table delivered Africa